illa refugee camp in Beirut has housed
Palestinian refugees since nineteen
forty nine Syrians and Palestinians
fleeing the war in Syria have swelled
their numbers to 40,000 Sammy Mahmoud
and omar ahmed have joined the DW
Academy citizen reporters training
program no honey here in the châtelet
refugee camp there's no press no one
reports from the camp we're taking that
job on and reporting firsthand going on
on about the La Fleur the site of
teenage video journalists is unusual
here Omar has even been detained by
security forces because he didn't have
permission to film the idea of a free
press is a new concept here a slogan
Khawaja yeah minus the couple and it's
hard to film people here hello she's did
I don't many don't want to be filmed
them for many of them it's completely
new they've never seen a video
journalist before we need to get
permission from the camp authorities
otherwise we're not allowed to film here
was that knee 14 teenagers both male and
female have been chosen for the DW
Academy course in cooperation with a
Syrian NGO based in the camp the
training includes research camerawork
editing and storytelling the young
reporters will start a community
platform in November run by refugees for
Refugees a pub annual support the madam
I would like to be the voice of the
young people here right now they're
invisible no one listens to them here in
the camp there was a lot of oppression
many things that people don't get to
hear about phone chimes citizen it's
harder for the young female reporters
some areas of the camp are off-limits
without a male escort but they refuse to
be held back I'm nominet how nominal
interview my love we're filming
interviews with people in the camp we're
trying to find out what people here need
Kevin how not offend knows who jawatan
so nos on their inquiries have already
borne fruit after conducting interviews
the reporters learned about some of the
problems in the camp
there's not enough water supply and
trash collection needs improvement so
does security those are today's
headlines from the new free press in the
shatila refugee camp